there are two schools of thought some
Entre entrepreneurs believe that mentors
and coaches are a huge integral part of
their life I know that I've had
spiritual mentors Financial mentors
career mentors I've had mentors in every
area of my life I see you as a mentor uh
on the other end there are entrepreneurs
who believe they're self-made that you
don't need mentors you don't need
coaches you don't need to listen to
anyone's advice where where do you sit
on that and how do you help young people
navigate that today because I think a
lot of people are are stuck trying to
figure it out or they're not doing
either properly as well the second group
is
stupid I but just be clear okay that was
very radically uh transparent I just
want to be clear they may confuse
the fact that um they may have good
instincts they have to make their own
decisions they can be um independent
thinkers that might do controversial
things in order to be successful that
all is true true okay that all is true
but the perspectives gained the learning
uh the wisdom that is gained the
open-mindedness the power of stress
testing your ideas I say that I think uh
everybody uh to be successful should be
assertive and open-minded at the same
time people ask well what is that merely
mean it means the you have to believe
you have to understand that at the same
time you have to doubt and pull out and
get the questions so that you stress
tested and that you're learning right
and so there's a great power in getting
the other perspectives you know
triangulation for me is the key to
success one of the keys to success
triangulation I mean get the three
smartest people that you know who will
care about you yeah and but will
disagree with you will stress test you
and and and have those conversations and
I like to have them disagree with each
other yeah so I I'll bring them into a
room and we'll have a conversation yeah
and then okay do the back and forth you
want to learn about anything like I have
big initiatives and where I don't know
anything and I have found that if I
follow that approach by getting the best
experts and I do that I can go into
things with the with the guidance so
it's so obviously stupid I think or so
obviously beneficial to be able to draw
upon the best thinking and then not to
just blindly believe so when I say it be
assertive and open-minded at the same
time don't just follow okay do the back
and forth hear the disagreements and
then resolve the disagreements it's an
extremely powerful approach